What the hell is that? What the hell are you wearing?
It's my suit!
Where's the case?
what case?
didn't you see the case
what?!
minor upgrade from Tony Stark
Aww, this is the coolest thing I've ever seen!
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
We finally get to share some footage.
So trailer dropping tomorrow is can be some
quick notes in my top five Spider-Man build
their actually seven Spiderman films almost
got made the.
So I talk about those extra ones two there
is a new round of the Spider-Man giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
Make sure to click that bell to enable alerts
you don't miss out on anything.
So, my Spider-Man trailer video will post
really late tomorrow night in case you guys
didn't know if they're going to post it, super
late.
So as long as you have alerts on you will
totally see when it drops.
So this is a version of the footage that they
showed off at Brazil, con is just like a slightly
different version because the trailer that
the dropping is much bigger.
Typically, when they show off, confident,
it's much shorter it's much more jumbled up.
If you couldn't tell he's jumping off the
Washington Monument like he's on a field trip
with his class like as of the people from
his class there.
You can see how well Jon Favreau as happy
Hogan will work in this like he has to babysit
Tony Stark, but the kind of like brothers
because they're almost the same age.
But then he scene with the kidneys just like
I got a babysit the kid hell.
But this is the briefcase that we saw in the
behind-the-scenes pictures I talked a little
bit about it I broke down the comic con footage
in a link that video at the end of this too.
But just get hype.
So there's gonna be way more Spider-Man footage
that nobody has seen before dropping tomorrow,
but let's rank our top Spider-Man films there
actually couple.
Spider-Man films that you might not know about.
They did not get made.
So most of you know about Andrew Garfield
and Toby McGuire era.
Spider-Man, but there were a couple really
crazy sounding.
Spider-Man movies that almost got made by
the same people that made those Superman movies
the ones that kinda drove that franchise into
the ground, but starting at the top.
You know favorite Spider-Man movie of all
time is still.
Spider-Man two Toby McGuire era that is still
one of the finest superhero films of the modern
era.
Now, I know there's been a lot of superhero
movies since that came out.
So it got knocked off the top perch for long
time it was my favorite superhero movie of
all time just really well made with the really
amazing villain performance from Dr. octopus,
but second favorite.
Spider-Man film is the first Toby McGuire
film yes I think that both of the Toby McGuire
films at least the first two are better than
the Andrew Garfield films so that first Spider-Man
film sort of rode the wave of really hopeful
awesome superhero films it came out after
Brian Singer's X-Men film that in my mind
was the beginning of really good big blockbuster
superhero films, the Brian Singer film then.
Spider-Man came right after that it was like
a one-two punch is like oh my God.
Spider-Man what an amazing character.
This is gonna be so awesome.
A lot of people felt like it was held back
by Toby McGuire's mopey performance he wasn't
motormouth Peter Parker the Tom Holland is
doing right now and you really didn't get
much of a chance to see him as a teenager
like he grew up really fast and that franchise,
especially in that first Spider-Man movie
credit where credit is due.
It gave us that classic Danny Elfman Spider-Man
theme that became so iconic that Danny Elfman
theme is kind of like the Jon William Superman
think it just became this instant classic,
but the funny thing about Spider-Man two is
that they used a Nickelback song to promote
one of the trailers and Nickelback is now
used in some places as punishment for criminals
and just for reference, though Michael Gia
Chino is scoring Spider-Man homecoming.
So he'll be the person to write the new, hopefully
iconic Spider-Man theme song, but number three
was the amazing Spider-Man which I felt like
was an interesting take on the character.
It was really like the Toby McGuire era.
Spider-Man done with better technology in
slightly different characters.
They opted for Gwen Stacy instead of maryjane
but I feel like it was held back a little,
just by the fact that they rebooted the Spider-Man
franchise so quickly and done the almost exact
same story.
They did the origin story get even though
they kind of messed around a little bit with
the villains.
But it was still a really entertaining film
it was still a lot of fun to watch.
But I feel like Andrew Garfield.
You know not true.
Peter Parker still cut in the way the Toby
McGuire at some of the bases but just didn't
ever quite encapsulate comic book Peter Parker,
so number four amazing Spider-Man to which
is kind of fell apart as the film just a little
overstuffed because they were trying to create
their Spider-Man cinematic universe before
the big fall at Sony before they made the
marble deal.
So there were a lot of good things in that
movie, but I feel like they kind of got lost
in the shuffle just because he got so crazy
in the film fell apart in the third act like
one of my favorite things of that film was
Jamie Foxx's character before they kind of
pushed him over the ledge of super crazy like
there was a note from Kevin fight heat that
he gave them notes on amazing Spider-Man two
and one of them said Jamie Foxx is doing some
really amazing stuff but we probably don't
need to go inside his apartment and makes
him seem too crazy, but sure enough they left
it in the movie and he started to seem just
completely bad she crazy.
But then as you probably guessed my number
five pick is Spider-Man three the Toby McGuire
film least favorite Spider-Man film that was
actually released in theaters, just because
it suffered from the exact same problems is
amazing Spider-Man two but it didn't have
a really great Jamie Foxx performance the
villains were quite as good.
I did not like to for grace even though I
love the idea that they were trying to work
venom into the Canon and he just started to
fall apart under its own weight.
You know same problem of hay.
This is the third movie.
So we got a make it bigger.
We get stuff more characters in their, without
worrying about how it was all going to fall
apart under its own weight.
So now we have a new Spider-Man film coming
out on have to rewatch all those it's been
a long time since I've watched some of the
Spider-Man movies but if you think a couple
of those were bad movies.
It was a Canon films version of the Spider-Man
movie that was in development Bob Hoskins
was going to be uncle Ben Tom Cruise was going
to be a college age Spider-Man, I know you
like wait a minute Tom cruises like in his
50s.
Now, when was this movie can be made.
It was actually closer to 1990 because this
was after that last Canon films Superman film
which was in the late 80s, so they did all
this development work.
Dr. octopus was going to be the villain that
they included all these noncanonical things
as you can imagine the way they treated the
Superman franchise it was going to be the
same deal for the Spider-Man franchise.
So it would have been a bit of a nightmare.
Luckily Tom Cruise opted not to do it.
So it all fell apart and the rights went elsewhere,
but is much of a B Spider-Man movie horror
show is that would've been the one sad thing
is that Stanley at the time wanted to play
J Jonah Jamison himself.
So what might've been.
I mean, he found his way into all the marvel
movies one way or another through his cameos.
So we got there eventually but then later
James Cameron picked up the option and then
you have like James Cameron era Spider-Man,
but he wanted to do the story of how Gwen
Stacy died that they essentially did an amazing
Spider-Man two that was gonna be a slightly
more hardcore version you've seen a lot of
James Cameron films so this was post aliens
1990s era James Cameron it would be like a
really big blockbuster, but also it would've
been super weird.
He wanted Edward Furlong for Peter Parker,
which would just completely throw me out of
the movie but the really cool thing is that
Lance Henriksen would've been his green goblin.
Just you know Lance Henriksen been in so many
James Cameron films so at that time it would've
totally made sense, but you have to imagine
like a slightly more serious version of green
goblin and say like Willem Defoe who played
it extra crazy other people on his list, so
it gets even more crazy Drew Barrymore is
Gwen Stacy remember this is about the death
of Gwen Stacy and Leonardo DiCaprio is Harry
Osborn.
Now this is still pretty titanic.
Leonardo DiCaprio so he was a big store but
not nearly as big as he is today.
Let me know in the comments what is your favorite
Spider-Man movies so far, assuming we haven't
seen Spider-Man homecoming yet and do you
think that Spider-Man homecoming will be your
new favorite after you see it.
We can't really say how good it's going to
be just because we haven't seen the whole
movie yet but we have seen Tom Holland's version
of Peter Parker.
So Allstate just seeing his performance in
Civil War in this trailer footage he seems
like a much more true version of the character
but they're doing the character in a way that
they haven't done him before just keeping
him a teenage superhero trying to live in
this bigger avengers world with all the stuff
that's been happening so far, so I'm just
so happy with the way things have gone down
the last couple years with the Sony marble
deal, and it gives me a lot of hope for fantastic
four other superhero franchises like the X-Men
films.
The only bummer about the X-Men stuff is that
Kevin fight he said that they are at an impasse
with Fox.
There is no deal that's going to be made any
time soon for that.
But when people ask him about that.
He's like yet know nothing is changed.
I see them every once in a while because he
was an executive producer on Brian Singer's
first X-Men fell he's friends with all those
Foxx people but on a business level like they'll
have boards of directors in army of lawyers
and suits.
They're just shaking their heads.
Note no deal not going to do it.
So Deadpool is gonna be really awesome.
Hopefully they can start making some really
awesome X-Men films to because of Sony can
get there.
Should together and do this marble stuff and
so can Foxx was can happen is is that after
I post my Spider-Man trailer video I will
do a Q&A that next day, so be sure to leave
all your Spider-Man questions avengers questions
infinity war anything you guys want me to
talk about, so later tonight arrow finale.
I know a lot of you are asking for an agents
of shield video I'll do that as soon as possible.
So, so much craziness.
Hopefully, you guys are on break from school
or you get some time off from work, but it's
going to be nuts will be doing a ton of Spider-Man
videos in the next couple weeks is going to
be a lot of fun.
While you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to learn all about.
Carnage and you can click here for last night's
flash finale video.
Thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!